[Applaudissements]
mons à laroque si vous nous rejoignez on
va ouvrir alors dit au matin
[Musique]
alors je vous rappeler la sortie multi
nakada connais tu lâches et le bon jeune
homme nous l'a dit et l'odeur la
soutiens au monde pierre veut absolument
nous verrons une fois c'est vrai bien
voulu ouvrir une foule violente et ça
s'applique au mans c'est à dire j'adore
ces très violents ce qui est allégué all
your et les faire aller pire à l'échec
avant d'entendre le commentant ces
l'auteur la pire au monde
il y a beaucoup de jeunes attendaient de
la tournée nous fait pas nous fait pas
pour l'instant je ne vole pas failli à
celui-là quitté vers loin mais je sais
c'est il paraît il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se sont sentis mal d'autres aides
caf sans rigoler non n'ouvrez pas tout
de suite
prenez des précautions quand même il ya
quelques secondes à quelques m'attendais
commence on veut sa prime les bêtes les
attentions certain temps les chéris s'il
ya des gens du public qui veulent sortir
maintenant vous pouvez y aller les
chéris procurez vous allez crever un
homme s'il ya des zones bleues mais qui
veulent sortir tout de suite vous pouvez
y aller les errements livre a atteint
son meilleur et j'espère
j'ai fait attention mais c'est encore
d'obtenir plus de la ville hercules
taipei a prévu capella corten factea
temps sur le g20 mais si la plage vers
moi la boîte qui pue attention on n'est
pas à temps on compte on fait un
décompte sera pas des comptes
cinq athlètes la dope
ben il ya des gens du public qui veulent
partir ce cas des gens inutilement
partir tout de suite
attention je vais attention
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez
sur l'ajoie toi
à eux
les sentir
bah c'était sinon ça aurait eu sur le
toit d'un potentiel c'est une horreur ce
qu'ont vu sur le plateau mais si vous
pouvez partir évacuer le plateau si vous
voulez évacuer le plateau
[Applaudissements]
partez et les mecs qui est lui qui
assume cardesse il a le plus grand et
plus beau du gauche malouda franchement
merci série khattabi les parties donc
d'eric en sera demain par bell veut le
faire devant les chéris c'est une
infection
merci de las palmas jalabert s'est très
vite il est d'accord merci les séries à
l'ehess complot nous verrons totalement
de parle on peut en ouvrir une totale -
ils voulaient manger thierry mauron
alors thierry besche commenge est
tellement mal à avaler a essayé d'en
manger
alors pour voir si c'est bon t'es gallas
c'est une horreur ce film de gilles
allez allez allez essayer essayé s'élève
à manger est la capitale
ouais
etc
or alive à manger comme ça c'est le cas
à ses jours sur son mari si genève
franchement merci en tout cas pas arrêté
là ça valait chéri tout et on va on va
je sais pas ça pour la cage où seulement
sont décollées il ya une odeur je ne
peuvent pas faire les missions dans son
agonie sont noirs et thierry vous en
mangerez demain il n'en mangera demandé
bus devait se retirer si tu me
remercient de celui d'avoir étalé tout
regarder joker d'heure merci d'avoir été
floués n'oubliez pas la télé cet égard
[Applaudissements]